biologists are challenging the idea of
naturalist Charles Darwin that evolution
cannot be observed in real time they
cite evidence from cities where
scientists study how animals and plants
interact with humans species either
adapt or face possible extinction and
one example birds get trapped every year
and 7,000 watt beams that shine in New
York City to mark the September 11th
attacks those birds have not evolved to
avoid artificial light but lizards in
Puerto Rico cities Puerto Rican cities
did evolve to better grip concrete and
metal surfaces with their feet urban
ecologists menno's skilled housing
discusses all of this in his new book
Darwin comes to town how the urban
jungle drives evolution man oh great to
have you on set with us so first of all
explain to us why anyone who's not an
ecologist should care about this subject
matter and why it's so important to us
as a species well it's it's because
cities are becoming the most important
ecosystem in the world we think of
nature and the ecosystem is something
that's out there but cities are growing
and basically there's not much nature
left as cities expand so whatever is
left of ecosystem is surviving in the
cities among us and is also evolving so
we can actually watch evolution shape
new ecosystems for the future in our
backyards and I think that's something
that everybody living in cities should
care about and you go back to Darwin's
theory and you talk about evolutions
over over hundreds of years if not
longer and you are now pointing to the
fact that maybe a lot of species can
adapt much quicker it is and and Darwin
thought that evolution could not be
observed he said we have to wait for for
millions of years for the lapse of Ages
and and fossils to be able to see it but
since then we've realized that evolution
is a much stronger process than Darwin
himself thought and it can actually be
observed in a matter of years especially
in insects that have short generations
times and which is basically the
evolutionary clock speed which is which
is very fast in these animals and you
can see them change under your eyes in
your own
is this a good thing it's it's it's
happening I'm not sure if it's a good
thing or a bad thing it's what evil
evolution does it adapts to changing
conditions well I guess if we're gonna
all be living in cities that cities are
getting bigger and bigger and we live
farther and further from more natural
environments that does seem to frighten
people yeah it does seem to frighten
people and at the same time Nature in
cities as I explained in my book it's
it's it's really new very exciting
ecosystems that are shaping from species
that have never met each other often in
the cities you find all these exotic
species that come from all over the
world and are forming new ways of living
with each other in cities just like
humans do in a way and they're adapting
to each other and forming a new fresh
ecosystem which is which is very
exciting to watch and that's why I think
the urban ecologist is somebody who's
going to have a lot of fun over the next
few days so help us understand the fun
that you're having with it that what are
you seeing that's exciting to you about
the animals that you're learning that
would be beneficial to us that we should
be excited about too for instance well
for instance city pigeons
yeah I mean the the rats of the air we
call them sometimes but but they're
really exciting animals they're they're
originally rock pigeons they live in
lifts on cliffs in in in southern Europe
and they've traded high buildings for
cliffs and they're dealing with all the
pollution that we throw at them for
example heavy metals there are all kinds
of heavy metals like zinc and lead
flaking of buildings and off lampposts
which produce pollution in the cities
and these these pigeons they evolved to
get rid of those heavy metals by putting
them in their feathers and you see that
the darker feathers are the ones with a
lot of melanin in they're better at
absorbing those heavy metals so they
detox themselves simply by having darker
feathers and that's real evolution that
you can see happening in the streets and
you learn something about the mice in
New York all right very telling it is
there's a white-footed Mouse which is
being studied by my colleague Jason
Mancha south important University he's
studying these white-footed mice that
live in remnants of forests in New York
they used to live everywhere when the
city wasn't there yet but they're now
surviving in Central Park and Prospect
Park and some of these bigger city parks
and they're adapting their sort of
marooned in these islands of forest in
the city and they're adapting to the
local conditions for example in Central
Park
Jason is finding that there they have
genes I've evolved genes that better
allow them to take care of very fatty
food because they're there they're
feeding on leftover and junk food that
people leave there and and also detox
themselves against aflatoxin which is a
toxin that grows on discarded peanuts so
these mice are eating that rather than
the stuff they used to eat before and
these populations are adapting they're
evolving to deal with all these new
things that are finding in these parks
you can learn a lot from talking to the
animals and punching with the animals
and think it started from you as a
little kid looking at bugs look at you
now yeah thank you very much man oh my
pleasure
Darwin comes to town goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books